Speaker 1: Conspiracy theorist and Infowars host
Alex Jones has made it clear that he is done with
Donald Trump and he is indeed going to be backing
Ron DeSantis if the Florida governor decides to
run for president in 2024. Now, as much as I'd
like to say, who cares what Alex Jones says, who
cares what he thinks? The guy is a nutcase, after
all, we can dismiss him. This actually is pretty
significant because if he's able to turn his loyal
viewers and listeners from being Trump supporters
and make them Ron DeSantis voters, well, that
could make the difference in a potential contested
primary between the two candidates. Let's
take a look at what Jones had to say
on his Infowars program earlier this week.
Speaker 3: Pigheaded support him
a few years ago. Even though I disagree
with his warp speed because I thought.
Then we had to keep him in office because of the
nightmare scenario if Hillary or Biden got in.
Back before they were officially
running. But that said, I am supporting
the Spanish. The saying is it's just
gone from being awesome to being
unbelievably good. And I don't just watch a man's
actions, as Christ said, to a tree by his fridge.
I can also look in his eyes on HD video. And I see
the real sincerity. This is what Trump should be
like. And I've been hammering this point, and
he's doing it now. And we have someone that
is better than Trump, way better than Trump.
Speaker 1: Now, at least in this clip, Alex
Jones did in articulate why exactly he likes Ron
DeSantis more than Donald Trump. And imagine it
has somewhat to do with the right wing culture war
issues that the Santos has been championing over
the past couple of years. Everything from making
these decrees against socialism to passing is.
Don't say gay bill to the anti-trans rhetoric to
saying that. Oh, well, the left supposedly wants
to defund the police. But here in Florida, we're
funding the police. But the real sticking point
for Jones seems to be the vaccine issue, the fact
that Donald Trump is not an outright anti-vaxxer,
at least as it pertains to the COVID vaccine.
And that's really just because he wants to take
credit for it, credit for Operation Warp Speed.
And Jones predicted, of course, that the vaccine
would do all these terrible things. But then you
look back and after billions of doses have been
administered, everyone's doing just fine.
So maybe he's moved the goalposts on that.
Just as a reminder, here's a clip from back
in December, when Alex Jones did a special
emergency Christmas Day edition of his show
to declare that Trump is ignorance or evil
because of his stance on the COVID vaccines.
Speaker 3: This is an emergency Christmas Day
warning to President Trump. You
are either completely ignorant
about the so-called vaccine gene therapy that
you helped ram through with Operation Warp Speed,
or you're one of the most evil men who has ever
lived to push this toxic poison on the public
and to attack your constituents when they simply
try to save their lives and the lives of others.
We're about to lay out the basic, incontrovertible
facts that what you told Candace Owens just a few
days ago is nothing but a raft of dirty lies.
Speaker 1: Now, maybe it's illogical for me
to try to get inside the head of Alex Jones and
understand why exactly he's making this pivot. And
who knows if Jones even believes half the things
that he says, right? So maybe he doesn't even care
one way or another between Trump or DeSantis.
But it is a little bit strange, right? Because
when Jones decided to hitches wagon to Trump back
in 2016, it at least made a little bit of sense
because Trump at the time was painting himself
as an anti-establishment figure. He was going to
be an outsider who would shake things up in
Washington and drain the swamp, as he like to say.
Ron DeSantis, though, on the other hand,
is pretty much just a standard Republican,
like he knows how to play the culture war games
better than the average Republican politician.
And he's clearly learned a thing or two from
Trump about how to deal with the media and how
to present himself. But at the end of the day,
he's a pretty establishment guy. Which Jones has
really never been into. So it's all very weird,
and I do think it actually could be relevant to
a potential matchup between the two figures.
So we'll have to see if maybe Ron DeSantis
ever decides to appear on Alex Jones's show like
Donald Trump did back in 2016. Maybe he won't,
because the scientists may realize that Jones is a
little bit too toxic right now to associate with,
but that's the latest Alex Jones done with
Donald Trump and moving over to Ron DeSantis.